ก็
สวัสดีครับครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูนี้สวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคนนะครับคู่
เอ๋สบายกูไหมวันนี้
ดูเสียงหัวเราะมีมีมีน้ำร้อนเหมือนกันค่ะ
ของนี้เป็นแก้วแต่ว่าข้างในเป็นกาแฟครับ
ของครูเอกเป็นน้ำร้อนน้ำอุ่นน้ำอุ่นน้ำ
เย็นแล้วก็นำร้อนเป็นน้ำอุ่นนะคะเพราะว่า
กูเอมี่ไอ
นิดหน่อย
หายไวๆนะครับ
ไม่มีตัวร้อนไม่มีอะไรแต่แปลกเจ็บอย่าคิด
ว่ากูเอ๋น่ะไปกินปูขอ
กินหมูครับกินไก่อ๋ออ๋อพิมพ์
มีเนื้อสัตว์ใช่ไหมครับปูหมูไก่ค่ะ
เกย์คุกกูอาจจะมีอาหารที่เป็นเนื้อสัตว์
น่ะหลายๆอย่างที่ห้ามกิน
นัดกินแล้วก็จะ I นี้
ขอบครับต้องกินแครอทกินบ๊อกโคลี่กินกิน
ผักก็ค่ะกินข้าว
ว่าจะไม่ไอแล้ว
ก็จะๆนิดนึงนะคะนักเรียนคุยคุยแล้วปุ๋ยกู
เองเงียบออกไปเองปิดคือแล้ว
ไม่ได้ยินใช่ 11 จะ I  love  you
I  love
มา
บอกไอ้นี่
III  One อภัยนะคะไม่ใช่ภาษาอังกฤษอ่ะ
ก็ได้เดี๋ยวคืนนี้
วันนี้ก็สบายดีไหมคะนิดสบายดีครับสบายดี
อ่ารับแล้วคุณนิอ่าครับตอนนี้จะบายดีไม่
มีแพ้ไม่มีจามไม่มีไอจริงๆคุณนิดเนี่ยคุณ
นิคคิดว่าคุณนิดน่าจะแพ้อ่าเกสรดอกไม้เขา
มีแต่ก็มีเกสรใช่ไทยเพราะว่าเหมือนกับ
ช่วงนี้ครับตอนนี้เนี่ยที่อเมริกาเป็นฤดู
ร้อนค่ะแล้วมันก็จะมีดอกไม้และดอกไม้มัน
ก็มีเป็นเกสรมันก็เหมือนจะเต็มอยู่ใน
อากาศมันปลิวมันปลิว
ลบ R ใช่แล้วมันก็พอมันปลิวผ่านไปผ่านมา
แล้วคุณก็จามอ่ะแต่ไม่ใช่อะไรจากไงแต่จำ
ครับมาครับ
แบบนี้อ่ะในขั้นๆ
ส่วนกูเองเนี่ยอ้ายไว้เซ่า
เคค่ะ
ขอให้เกสรดอกไม้หายไปเร็วๆนะหายไปเร็วๆ
ใช่ครับใช่
แล้วนะคนนี้เคยหายหน้าจอดทำไมอยู่กันก่อน
ว่าวันนี้วันนี้วันอะไรคะไม่คุยเขียนไหม
หรือคนที่อยากเขียนเองครูเอ๋
เขียนดีกว่าพอได้ครับแต่เดี๋ยวคุณนิคจะ
ขีดเส้น
ก่อนว่าได้ประมาณนี่โอเคครับ
โอเคครับ
วันนี้วันนี้วันอะไรครับผมโอเควันนี้ล่ะ
คะค่ะวันนี้เราเจอกันวันอังคารมั้ยใช่วัน
อังคาร
เจ๊เราไม่ได้เจอวันพฤหัสบดีเจอวันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะคุณนี้วันที่ 28 ครับ 28
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนมิถุนายนครับเดือน
มิถุนายนปีพตอะไรคะดีผช
2565 ครับปีคศอะไรคะมีข้อ
2022 ครับค่ะแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอน
นี้เมืองที่คุณนิดอยู่นะครับเวลาแปดโมง 13
นาทีตอนเช้า
8 โมง 13 นาทีนะคะส่วนที่ครูเอ๋อยู่
ประเทศไทยก็เป็นถ้า 20:00 น 13 นาที
บางคืนเนาะครับมันคืนครูนี่กับครูเอ๋
เนี่ยเวลาห่างกัน
ของชั่วโมงชาย
12 ชั่วโมงนะคะ
โอเคเจอกับคุณนิกับเราก็ต้องมาฟังเรื่อง
เราใช่ไหมคะคนนี้อายครับ
นิทาน
นิทานนิทาน
วันนี้ครับคุณนิคมีนิทาน 1 เรื่องไม่รู้
ว่าครูเอ๋เนี่ยเคยได้ยินไหมนิทานเรื่อง
นี้ค่ะเรื่องอะไรคะนิทานเรื่องนี้ครับ
ชื่อเรื่องคือคนขายเกลือกับลา
คนไข่เกลือกับลาก็แสดงว่าต้องมีคนชาติมี
คนผู้ชายหรือผู้หญิงค่ะผู้ชายครับก็จะมี
คนคนกี่คนคะหนึ่งคนครับอันหนึ่งคนนะคะ
แล้วมีมีอะไรอีกนะลานอ่ะกับชายหล่าคู๋ลอง
วาดก่อนนะเออลองดูลองดูนะเอกจะวัดแบบไหน
เวลาเลยมันหนูเนี่ย
เหมือนไม่คุณนี่เหมือนก็ได้นะครับ
เดี๋ยวโอเค
หรือว่าอันนี้เป็นหมานะครับนั่นน่ะสิไม่
เป็นไรว่ารักหมากระต่าย
ไม่เป็นไรเพราะว่าคุณอีกไม่มีรูปถ้า
โอเคค่ะขอดูรูปดีกว่าค่ะได้ครับเดี๋ยวคน
ในเกรดลบลบเอา
หัว
หน้ามาก็มีผู้ชาย
อันนี้ครับคนนี้ครับเขาก็เป็นคนขายเกลือ
ชายที่มีหมวกสีเขียวนะครับแล้วก็
ด้านขวาเนี่ยตัวนี้คือลา
เหมือนๆมาเนาะเหมือนกันครับแต่ว่ากลัวตัว
จะเล็ก
เขาเรียกว่าคล้ายดีกว่าเนาะไม่ใช่เหมือน
ขายครับนะฮะคล้ายกับม้าแต่หาญหางตรงนี้
ขานของลา
ขายขายของลากับหางของม้าไม่เหมือนกันใช่
ไหมคะไม่เหมือนครับไม่เหมือน 5 คุณนิคจำ
ไม่ผิดนะอ่าหน้าจะสั้นปั้นครับ
ครับก็มีค่ะมีผู้ชายขายกับเกลือๆคะ
แล้วก็มีลาครับก็คุณนี้คิดว่าสมัยก่อน
เนี่ยเขาจะใช้ลาในการขนของเวลามีของหนักๆ
ของเยอะเขาก็จะเอาล่ะเนี่ยมามาช่วยครับ
ชายแบบของข้างหลังคำ
ว่ามาก่อนไม่มีรถเนาะใช่ไม่มีรถครับหรือ
อาจจะมีแต่รถแพงมากๆเป็นรถที่จะเป็นล้อ
เกวียนแต่ถ้ามีลามันก็ง่ายเพราะว่าก็เป็น
สัตว์ที่อยู่ในป่าแล้วก็เอามาเอามาแบกของ
ครับค่ะๆ
เขาต่ออันนี้ครับ
เป็นเกี่ยวกับคนขายเกลือกับลาไปอ่าเรื่อง
เป็นยังไงคะคนขายเกลือกับราเนี่ยจออันนี้
ครับเรื่องเนี่ยมันก็เกิดขึ้นว่าคนขาย
เกลือเนี่ยเขาก็จะเอาเกลือเอาไปขายใช่ไหม
ครับแต่ทางตัวนะมันไม่ได้เกลืออันเล็กๆ
ที่ว่าเราเห็นตามโต๊ะร้านอาหารที่เป็นใส่
กระปุกอันเล็กๆนะมันเป็นเครือแบบนี้เลย
ขอเป็นเป็นกระสอบละฮะใช่ครับกลายเป็น
กระสอบใหญ่ๆเดี๋ยวคุณลิขิตต่อรถโค๊ตจะได้
วาดรวมค่าที่โต๊ะอาหารนี่ก็จะเป็นแบบนี้
เนาะเป็นที่เป็นกระปุกเกลือแบบนี้ข่าวก็
มีรูเดียวใช่
ลืมค่ะถ้าเป็น 3 รูนี้ก็พริกไทยชายครับก็
เป็นเกลือก็ 1  1 รูแล้วก็เราก็มีที่นี่
มีอะไรนะ 5  Stars แล้วปะถ่ายรักสะเต๊ะ
แล้วก็จะ Take เผื่อใสชายไอคำอันนี้ก็จะ
เป็นแบบเกลือถุงกระสอบใหญ่ๆเลยแบบขำๆหมู่
บ้านคุณนิดมีไหมคะเนี่ยเกลือเป็นกระสอบ
ล่ะครับ
คุณอีกเสียงตกใจวะ
จะเกิดกระสอบแบบนี้นี่น่าจะใช้ได้หลายสิบ
ปี
ไม่ไม่ต้องกินอย่างเดียวคุณนี้บางทีเอาไป
ใส่ปลาน้ำหรอครับอาบน้ำเลยเหรอ
ใส่สระว่ายหน่อยหรออ๋อให้เป็นน้ำเกลือใช่
ไหมใช่เดี๋ยวนี้เขาเขาไม่ใส่คอลีนเขาใส่
เกลือกันอ๋อเออใช่ใช่คนนี้เคยได้ยินอยู่
นะสระน้ำที่เป็นสระน้ำเกลือ
เธอเป็นแบบนี้กูจะดีกับสุขภาพมากกว่า
สัตว์ที่เป็นคลอรีนแล้วก็เขาใส่อันนี้
ด้วยค่ะคุณนี้ใส่ที่ห้องน้ำค่ะ
ที่ที่
โถส้วมตรงเนี้ยก็ใส่เกลือ
We  Are ค่ามีกลิ่นหรือว่าอ่ะไม่ค่อยดี
เขามาจะใส่เกลือลงไปสำหรับร้านขอ
สำหรับล้างทำความสะอาดใช่ไม่เคยไม่เคยได้
ยินเขาเพราะว่าเมื่อก่อนนะคนนี้ที่ทำ
เนี่ยเพราะว่าถ้าเกิดว่าห้องน้ำเนี่ยมัน
มีกลิ่นหรือแบบมันไม่สะอาดคุณนี่กับจะเอา
ซันไลมาชี
ใส่อ่างล้างจานนะคะ
ใช่ฉันไม่เอาน้ำยาล้างห้องน้ำนะก็คือกิน
ว่าน้ำยาล้างเลนส์มันนิกลิ่นมะนาวแล้วมัน
มันล้างพวกจานพวกคราบทีเรียใช่ก็เลยคิด
ว่ามันก็น่าจะช่วยได้ครับ
เอาไปซักผ้าด้วยนะคะครับถ้าไม่เคยครับ
อย่างนะยังไม่สะอาดใหญ่ๆให้นักเรียนมี
ประโยชน์หลายอย่างครูนิคบางทีนะเวลาถ้า
เราเจ็บคอเนี่ยเราก็มีน้ำใช่มะมีแก้วน้ำ
ครับเดี๋ยวแก้วน้ำเราก็เอาเกลือเนี่ยใส่
แล้วก็ใส่น้ำร้อนอือข่าวเสร็จน้ำร้อนก็
ใส่น้ำร้อนแล้วก็คนแล้วเราก็
กลัวคอใช่มันก็จะช่วยนะช่วยเรื่องขอถ้า
เราแบบเจ็บคอหรือมีอะไรแบบเนี้ยเจ็บคอไม่
ใช่เหรอครับ
เอาไม่เจ็บค่ะแต่ว่าคันเออ 8 คันครับใหม่
นะมันเก่าอย่างนี้ไม่ได้นะมันต้องลองเข้า
ไปกับครับไม่น่า
คือนักเรียนคือครูเอ๋มีปัญหาที่ใส่นัดตรง
นี้
เคยแตกแล้วก็มีเลือดด้วย
ก็ต้องหยุดกินโปรตีนแปลจีนนะๆหยุดกินอะไร
นะเป็นปลายอ่ากินอะไรที่ทอดอ่ะไม่ได้นะฮะ
ถ้ากินปั๊ปเนี่ยมันจะมีอะไรนะมีก็ได้ is
มีน่ะออกมาเยอะๆแล้วมันก็เป็นเป็นแผลแล้ว
มันทีมีเลือดมีเลือดออกไปดิ
เออ
โอเคพอมันลงมาที่คอมันก็จะคันขอ
เดี๋ยวเสร็จค้าแล้วกูเอกจะไปเอาน้ำเกลือ
แล้วก็กลัวคอโอเคจะได้ก็ลงไปนะคะนักเรียน
อ้วนแต่ไม่ต้องกลืนนะคะหรือไม่ได้ครับ
M ใช่ใช่ก็อันนี้ครับก็คือเป็นเกลือ
ที่เป็นกระสอบทรายแต่ว่าคุณนี้คงไม่ซื้อ
เยอะขนาดนี้เลยมาอีกนิดซื้อแค่นิดเดียว
ขนาดขวดเล็กๆเนี้ยบางทีคนนี้จะใช้
ทำงานนะแบบ
เกือบ 1 ปีอะกว่าจะหมด
ชาร์จไม่ทำอาหารอ่ะทำครับแต่ว่าคุณนี้ก็
จะใส่เกลือแบบไม่เยอะเพราะว่าเวลาทำอาหาร
ไทยอ่ะครับมันก็จะมีเหมือนซีอิ๊วคุณนี้ก็
ชอบใส่ซีอิ้วมากกว่าเอ่อซอสถั่วเหลือง
ครับถ้าถ่ายแล้วมันก็มึงอยู่แล้วมันมี
เกลืออยู่แล้วไงก็เลยไม่ต้องใส่เกลืออีก
หาชายส่วนส่วนครูเอ๋นี้ตอนนี้ใช้แต่เกลือ
เออโอเคอาบน้ำปลาซีอิ๊ว to  you ไม่ได้
ถ่ายเลยเกลือก็เลยจะใช้เกลือเยอะกว่าคุณ
เล็ก 1 ปีก็จะ 2
2 กระปุกเล็กๆค่ะครับก็ไม่ได้ซื้อเป็น
กระสอบนะคะว่าอย่างนี้นะอย่างนี้นักเรียน
เราเรียกว่ากระสอบของครูเอ๋จะเป็นเล็กๆ
ออกแบบนี้
จะเป็นเด็กหมูเราก็เรียกว่ากระปุกใช่ไหม
กระปุกค่ะแล้วตอนนี้ก็จะมีช้อนครับ
ไม่ว่ากระปุกเกลือแต่เล็กๆนะคะเด็กๆไม่
ได้
แล้วก็อาหารซะเท่าไหร่ 200 กรัม
ประมาณ 200-300 กรัมแต่ว่าถ้ากระสอบวัน
นี้เนี่ยโอ้อันนี้นี่ 5 กิโลกรัม
Over นี้น่าจะมากกว่า 5 กิโลนะครูเอ๋
มันน่าจะ 10 กิโลครับกิโลนะครับนี่ก็เป็น
กระสอบเกลือถ่ายครับใจแล้วผู้ชายคนที่คุณ
นิคะบอกน่ะเขามีอาชีพขายเกลือเหรอคะใช่
ครับ
ได้คือเขาเนี่ยก็พ่อเอาเกลือเนี่ยครับเอา
ไปขายให้คนอื่นก็
หมอเขาจะเอาไปขายเนี่ยเขาก็จะเอาเกลือนะ
ครับกระสอบใหญ่ๆเนี่ยเอาวางไว้บนหลังลา
เราก็ก็เดินเดินไปออกไปขาย
ครับชายราตัวนี้เขาเลี้ยงเอาไว้นะคะคนนี้
ให้ครับใช่ใช้เป็นลาที่เขาเอาไว้ใช้เวลา
ขนของขนเกลือครับอะไรเพราะมนุษย์เยอะเรา
นั่นน่ะข้าขอชนะเขาก็ถือคนเดียวไม่ได้
เขารักราวตัวนี้ไหมคะก็เขาก็รักนะครับเขา
ก็รักเพราะว่าตอนแรกก็โอเคตรวจลาเนี่ย
ช่วยขนของขับช่วยขนของช่วยให้เขาได้มี
เงินเพราะว่าเขาเอาเดี๋ยวไปขายใช่ไหมงั้น
เขาก็ต้องมีหญ้าลากินหญ้าใช่มั้ย
ใช่สิ
หากินยากมาให้จะเอาหญ้าให้ลากินเนาะ
แต่อะไรคะออนไลน์เนี่ยลาตัวนี้นะคือมันมี
เหตุการณ์ครับเพราะว่าวันนึงเนี่ยขายใน
รูปภาพวันนี้ครับก็เขาก็เดินเดินไปเพราะ
ว่าทางจากบ้านเขาไปขายเกลือนั้นมันก็จะมี
แม่น้ำแบบนี้ต้องเดินผ่านแม่น้ำทุกครั้ง
ครับเรามีอยู่ 1 วันมันมีอุบัติเหตุเพราะ
ว่าลาเนี่ยเดินเดินเดิน
ข้ามแม่น้ำแล้วเขาล้ม
ๆครับจะเจอก้อนหินเนาะไม่นานใช่ก็อันนี้
นะครับเขาก็จะล้มแบบนี้แต่ว่าตอนที่เขา
ล้มเนี่ยคือเขาล้มเพราะเป็นอุบัติเหตุ
เนาะก็เดี๋ยวคนนึกเสียว่าลมเป็น
อุบัติเหตุคนไข่เครือเนี่ยเขายังไม่อ่ะนะ
ก็เขาอ๋อ
อุบัติเหตุนี่ใช่เนี้ยพ่ออุบัติเหตุใช่
ไหมครับณิกณิกเวลาล้มลงไปปั๊บเนี่ยแล้ว
เกิดอะไรขึ้นกับตัวเยอะเหรอก็เกลือครับ
มันก็ตกลงไปในน้ำแบบนี้ค่ะนายขาวก็เนี่ย
อันนี้ครับก็เป็นสกัดสอบเกลือใช่ไหมครับ
เพราะมันตกลงไป next น้ำเนี่ยพอที่เกิด
ขึ้นน่ะมันก็จะเป็นอย่างนี้เกลือเนี่ยก็
เป็นลงไปในน้ำมันก็เหมือนละลาย
พี่โดนน้ำก็หายไปเลยให้หายไปเลยแล้วก็
เพราะมันหายไปเลยน่ะคนขายเกลือที่เห็นตรง
เนี้ยเขาก็เอ้าอะไรนะเสียใจเพราะว่าไม่มี
เกลือไปขายก็ไม่ได้เงิน
ๆน่าสงสารจังเลยใช่คนไทยแต่เขาไม่ได้โกรธ
ล่ะใช่ไหมคะเขาไม่ได้โกรธล่ะครับเขาก็แบบ
ก็เป็นอุบัติเหตุ
ก็ต้อง Tiger ก็
มีน้ำตาละ
วันนี้ไม่ได้เงินแล้วแต่ไม่เป็นไรนะลาเคย
ตีติดเกิดขึ้นได้
แต่ที่นี้เนี่ยลาครับลามันเจ้าเล่ห์
ทำไมอ่ะขอลาได้เหมือนคิดไม่ดีเพราะเนี่ย
พอเป็นอุบัติเหตุครั้งแรกนะครับที่เขาล้ม
ลาล้ม - เกลือมันก็ตกแล้ว
ลาก็คิดแล้วเจ้าเล่นครับละลายสิก็ไปขาย
ของไม่ได้ใช่มั้ยใช่ใช่
- เกลือที่ลาแบบมาพอมันละลายมันก็เออมัน
ไม่ต้องแบบของหนักแล้วมันเบาๆมันเบาใช่ลา
ครับก็เจ้าเล่ห์เนี่ยตอนนี้มันก็เห็นว่า
ละลายเนี่ยก็คิดได้แล้วปิ้ง
โอเค
เว็บสีแดงมีข่าว
ชาร์จคิดได้แล้ว
แบบนี้เนี่ย
แต่เราฮ่าๆเลยกำลังวาดปิ๊ง
หาฉัน
นาน
ได้กิ๊บได้แบบเจ้าเล่ห์ว่าเอ๊ะแบบนี้
เนี่ยเดี๋ยวทำอีก
แป้งครับแกล้งล้ม
อ้าวเพราะว่าเราไม่อยากเดินไปขายของเพราะ
ลาไม่อยากแดกเกลือเยอะๆมันหนาวเอา
ให้ล่ะ
ไม่อย่างน่ะของชายจริงๆเรื่องนี้ล่ะพูด
ได้ไหมคะเวลาเราเล่านิทานนะอยากจะวันทีลา
พูดได้แต่เรื่องนี้นะพูดไม่ได้ใช่ไหมคะ
ไม่ได้แต่ว่าเราก็จะเราอ่าเพื่อเห็นมัน
ไม่นี้ท้ายก็จะบอกเวลาก็คิดว่าจะทำแบบนี้
ขับค่ะๆชายตลาเนี่ยไม่ได้พูดกับคนขาย
เกลือแต่แค่คิดกับตัวเองว่าแบบเอ๋ต้องทำ
แบบนี้จะได้ไม่ต้องแบบของหนักครับใช่
เนี่ยเขาคิดนี้วันต่อไปวันต่อไปครับวัน
ต่อไปครับคนขายเครือก็เอาเกลือเน็ตกระสอบ
เยอะๆเนี่ยครับมาวางบนหลังลาค่ะเนี้ยลาก็
เดินเดินไปจนถึงแม่น้ำอันเดิมแม่น้ำสาย
เอิ่มก็เดินห้ามแล้วก็
ล้มอีกๆแต่อันนี้เห็นไหมครับว่าลานอ่ะเขา
ก็เหมือนกับยิ้มใช่ยิ้มใช่เหมือนไม่ได้
รู้สึก
เสียใจจิตใช่ไม่รู้สึก
[เพลง]
หน้าฝากอ่าผู้เขียนเนี่ย
ก็ล้มแบบนี้อีกทีนี้เนี่ย
คนขายเกลือเนี่ยทำยังไงคะคือพอล้มได้ตอน
นี้ครับมันยังเป็นเกลือคนขายตัวกับเขา
เริ่มคิดและว่าเอ๊ะทำไม
ล้มอีกแล้วก็หนาวไม่แข็งแรงหรือเปล่าเออ
เฮ้ยไอ้พี่เนี้ยเขาก็คิดว่าเอ๊ะล้มอีก
แล้วเกลือเนี่ยมันก็ละลายอีกแล้วไม่ได้
เงิน
ขายไม่ได้เฮ้ยขายไม่ได้ทีนี้ครับคือลา
เนี่ยก็พอล้มแล้วก็ดีใจแล้วไม่ต้องแบกของ
หนักกลับมากลับบ้านต้องทำงานๆแต่ที่เรียก
เนี้ย
ชอบ
ลาชอบเพราะว่าเธอไม่ต้องแบบของไม่เป็นไร
ละบาวโอ
แต่คนขายเกลือชอบไหมคะคนขายเผื่อไม่ชอบ
ครับเพราะว่าแต่ตอนนี้เขาก็เริ่มแบบโกรธ
แล้วเติบ
ทําไมอะไรมีอะไรใช่ใช่ทำพลาดครั้งที่ 1
โอเคครับทำราดทางที่สองเออเริ่มคิดรักมัน
ต้องมีอะไรแปลกๆค่ะมีครั้งที่ 3 ไหมก็
เมียครับครั้งที่ 3 เนี่ยมันก็มีก็เป็น
แบบนี้อีกขอคำซ้ำเรื่อยๆๆทำซ้ำ 2 ครั้ง 3
ครั้งทำซ้ำเรื่อยๆเหมือนเดิม
อันนี้เลยว่าทำผิดแล้วนะคนนี้เฮ้ย
คือครั้งแรกเนี่ยครั้งที่ 1 เนี่ย
อุบัติเหตุครับไม่ได้คิดแบบอุบัตเหตุมัน
พลาดแต่ว่าครั้งที่ 2 เนี่ยทำผิดล่ะค่ะ
ครั้งที่ 3 ด้วยก็ผิดนะคะไม่ขับและก็
เหมือนจะทำผิดซ้ำๆเราก็ต้องขายเกินแล้วก็
คิดแล้วว่ามันลานเนี่ยตั้งใจ
ใช่ครับทำไมจะล้มบ่อยๆล้มทุกวันแล้วล้ม
ที่เดิมด้วย
ครับทีนี้เนี่ยคนขายคนขายลาทำยังไงอ่ะตี
ลาไหมคนขายเกลือครับไม่ใช่คนใช่ลา
ไม่คิดอะไรก็คิดว่าคนขายโรตีลาวเยอะอยาก
จะเอาลาไปขายแล้วได้แน่
ไม่เวลากูเองฟังเสร็จครูเอกก็คิดถึงกันทำ
งานอาจเวลาทำงานน่ะมันไม่มีใครแบบอัด 100%
ข่าวถูกต้องอาจจะมีผิดมีพลาดนะคะแต่ไม่
ใช่ทุกวันทุกวัน
หรือว่าไม่ใช่เหมือนเดิมตลอด 1 ก็แปลว่า
ไม่ได้พัฒนาไม่ได้เปลี่ยนไม่ได้ปรับปรุง
แล้วสะอาด
ครับก็เลยอยากรู้ว่าคนขายเกลือปีเปล่าวะ
น่ะคนขายเกลือน่ะไม่ตีล่ะก็ใจดีใจดีแต่
แต่ว่าเกลือเนี่ยคิดครับคิดเราก็เหมือน
กับวางแผน
ชาย
ชายคน
โอเค
วางแขนก็มีมีอันนี้ใช่ไหมครับก็มี
ลิงค์ขึ้นมาครับเอารูปก่อนโอเคลบให้นกให้
[เพลง]
ไม่หายเกลือแล้วหรอคะตอนนี้ไม่ขายเกลือ
ครับเพราะว่าอ่ะอยู่ในครั้งแล้วหลาย
เพื่อนเอาครับ
ก็พอมันหลายครั้งครับคนขายเกลืออะไรก็คิด
ว่าเอ๊ะต้องลองต้องลองทำอะไรสักอย่างนึง
เพราะจะดูว่าลาเนี่ยจะเป็นหนังกันไหมจะ
ล้มอีกไหมที่เนี้ยคนขายเกลือครับเขาก็ไป
เอาอันนี้มาครับแล้วก็จะเรียกว่าอะไรคะ
อันนี้ครับเป็นนุ่นครับใช้อันนี้ก็มาจาก
ต้นครับต้นนุ่นมันก็จะเป็นอย่างนี้ข่าว
นุ่นเนี่ยคนไทยเอามาใส่หมอนใช่ไหมๆใส่
หมอนหรือว่าใส่ตุ๊กตาให้มันนุ่มๆครับใช่
หรอกก็เราก็แบบเห้ย
เบาๆชา
ครับแต่ว่าคนขายเกลือเนี่ยเขาก็เหมือนกับ
เปลี่ยนครับลาไม่รู้นะลาก็ยังว่าเอ๊ย
เดี๋ยวอีกวันนึงก็ขน
อ่าเกลือแล้วก็ล้มอีกจะได้เบาก็ไม่แล้วก็
ไม่ต้องไปขาย
ให้ทีนี้ครับคนขายเกลือนั้นเขาก็เปลี่ยน
กระสอบไม่บอกลาก็ใส่กระสอบในกระสอบก็จะมี
นุ่นเยอะครับๆแล้วก็ให้ไลน์เนี่ยแบบรุ่น
บนหลังแต่เรารู้สึกว่าเออเป็นเกลือนใช่
แต่นู้นมันจะบ่าวไม่ใช่เหรอคะคนนี้ค่ะใช่
รุ่นเนี่ยมันเบาครับแถว 5 มันก็จะมีมันก็
จะมีข้ออีกอย่างหนึ่งก็คือท่านนุ่นมันโดน
น้ำมันไม่อ่านไลน์เหมือนเกลืออ้ามันจะ
เป็นยังไงคะมันจะอุ้มอุ้มน้ำไว้ก็คือหนัก
กว่าเดิม
เพราะว่าเหมือนกันนุ่มนุ่นเก็บน้ำใช่ครับ
เรือละลายน้ำช้าๆก็ตอนตอนที่เราแบบแต่ก็
น่าจะไม่หนักมากนะช้าเพราะว่าถ้าสมมติ
เรือเรือทักษิตกระสอบโอก็จะหนักมากๆแต่
ถ้านุ่น 10 กระสอบนี้เบาเบาๆเลยนะใช่เบาๆ
แต่ล่าก็ไม่ได้หยิบไงครับแล้วก็แบบเออวัน
นี้เบาดีเนาะเป็นเกลือนั้นไม่เยอะใช่ลา
ไม่รู้ว่าคนขายเกลือเปลี่ยน
แล้วเกิดอะไรขึ้นคะอะไรขึ้นครับก็คนขาย
เกลือแนวก็เดินเดินครับก็จะเอาของไปขาย
ใช่ไหมครับนางก็คลิปจะทำไม่ดีเหมือนเดิม
ครับที่นี้เดินมาที่แม่น้ำล้มอีกให้ล้ม
อีกครั้งที่ 4
โอเค
ครับที่ดีเนี่ยก็ดีใจแบบนี้ว่าเออร้อง
เดี๋ยวจะสบายแล้วเขาบ้านหมู่บ้านเพราะ
เรือเกลือเนี่ยมันก็ละลายแล้ว
เบาๆไม่มีอะไร
แต่ว่าเพราะคนขายเครือเขาวางแผนไว้แล้วก็
สิ่งที่เกิดขึ้นครับคืออันนี้นะวันนี้
ก่อน
รู้
ก็คือไม่ละลายน้ำไม่ละลายน้ำครับเพราะว่า
ตอนที่ลานล้มลงไปปกติเนี่ยก็จะยืนขึ้นมา
ได้เพราะเกลือมันละลาย
ไปในน้ำอะไรครับแต่ครั้งนี้เนี่ยขอข้างใน
มันเป็นนู่นข้อมันคนน้ำเนี่ยมันก็เก็บน้ำ
ไว้ข้างในหนักกว่าเดิมหลายเท่าครับ
ให้ตอนและมาเบาๆตอนนี้นักเลยหนักกว่าเดิม
ใช่แล้วก็เดินไปต้องเดือนมั้ยใช่จะเอาไป
ขายได้ไหมเนี่ยเอาไปข้างหน้าก็ไม่รู้ว่า
มีพระอาทิตย์
อาทิตย์ร้อนๆครับชายก็น่าจะเอาไปขายได้
แต่เพราะว่าอันนี้ครับคนขายเกลือเนี่ยเขา
ทำอย่างนี้เพราะเขาว่าจะสอนลาลาเขาอยาก
รู้ว่าลาเนี่ยทำผิดอีกไหม
ถ่ายพ่อเหมือนจะเข้าจับได้แล้วไงครับแล้ว
นะเจ้าเล่ห์เห้ยล่ะก็แบกรุ่นหนักๆไปหาย
แบบก็มีพระอาทิตย์ใช่ไหมคะน้ำไหลลงไป
เรื่อยๆนุ่นก็จะเบาขึ้นเบาขึ้นเป่าคืนไม่
ได้เมามากนะคะนักเรียนพัฒนามอยู่ที่ไหน Hi
เนี่ยครับโคล่าเห็ดแล้วก็ลิ้นห้อยคอด้วย
ครับลาน่าจะคิดไม่น่าล้มเลย
ใช่เขา
ก็หลังจากนั้นหลัง
จากนั้นก็คือลาก็รู้สึกรู้สึกผิดและเพราะ
ว่าว่าเอาทำผิดหลายๆครั้งแบบนี้เนี่ยคนก็
รู้แล้วค่ะๆครับเพราะมันผิดเหมือนเดิมคน
ที่เขาเคยโดนเหมือนเดิมเนี่ยเขาก็เริ่ม
คิดแล้วว่า a มันมีอะไรแปลกๆแล้วล่ะก็รู้
แล้วว่าตัวเองอ่ะทำไม่ดีๆทำไม่ดีครับมัน
ก็ไม่ดีก็ย้อนกลับมาถ่ายๆคำถ้าเขาข้ามแม่
น้ำดีๆเขาก็ไม่หนักใช่ไหมใช่เขาก็ไม่หนัก
นะเขาก็จะขนของธรรมดาใช่สรุปนะอย่าขี้
เกียจใช่มั้ยหลายขี้เกียจไม่อยากทำงานเธอ
เช้า
ก็เลยเออคือทำงานนะเนาะลาก็เหมือนคนทำงาน
ก็ไม่ไม่ควรจะซิกแซ็กให้เสียหายอะไรอ่ะนะ
ครับก็ทำอะไร
แบบไหนแล้วมันไม่ได้ทำให้คนอื่นมันเสีย
ประโยชน์ค่ะใบดีแล้วใช่ครับทำให้เจ้า
เล่ห์ไม่รู้สึกขี้เกียจไม่อยากทำงานกับ
เนี้ยทำๆมันก็จะมีมันก็จะมีผลตามมามันกับ
ถ้าเราทำไม่ดีกับใคร
ไงดีใช่มันก็จะกลับมาหาเราอยู่ดีอือเพราะ
โคตร 6 กูแล้วก็จะได้
ว่าแกขี้เกียจแล้วนะแก่เจ้าเล่ห์แล้วนะๆ
ใช่ครับอันนี้ครับก็เหมือนก็เป็นเอ่อคำ
สอนขับเราก็จะเรียกว่าเป็นคติสอนจ่ายขับ
วัดนั่งนี้คือคำไม่ดีในหลายครั้งเนี่ยคน
เขารู้ครับอย่าไปคิดว่าคนอื่นเขาไม่ก็ไม่
รู้ชายทั้งที่หนึ่งเพราะอาจจะต้องไม่เป็น
ไรครั้งที่สองเออฉันนิสาว 6 ครั้งที่ 4
ไม่ได้นะคะใช่ก็เราก็รู้ครับถ้าทำไม่มี
เหมือนเดิมแบบเดิมมาหลายครั้งเนี่ยทนเขา
ก็รู้ว่าเอ๊ะมันแปลกๆๆแปลว่าไม่แปลว่า
ตั้งใจทำไม่ดีใช่ไหมชายครั้งอย่างงั้นคะ
ถ้าทำไม่ดีแต่ไม่เหมือนเดิมไม่เป็นไรใช่
แล้วทำไม่ดีคนทำไม่ดีไม่เหมือนเดิมคนก็จะ
คิดว่าเอ๊ะหรือจะทำไม่ได้จริงๆนะเพราะว่า
มันก็เหมือนเดิม
ราษแต่ก็ไม่มีไม่ควรทำ
จริงๆไม่คนทำนะคะไม่ขึ้นทำไม่ดี
อุบัติเหตุเกิดได้
ทำให้เกิดอุบัติเหตุบ่อยๆอันนี้ไม่ดีชนะ
คายถามเพราะคนก็จะเริ่มคิดแล้วอ่ะเฮ้ยอัน
นี้มันตั้งใจจะทำหรือไม่ได้ตั้งใจคือครับ
ฉายกับมันแล้วเดินไปชนน่ะโอ้ยเจ็บ
หน้าแม่ๆวันนี้ถ้าทำอาหารไม่ได้นะแขนเจ็บ
มือข้าวเสร็จแล้วก็เจ็บทุกวัน
ใช่
อันนี้มันขี้เกียจนี่
คุณแม่ก็บอกงั้นไม่ต้องกินลูก
นะคะ
ฉันครับก็เป็นนิทานสำหรับวันนี้หนังนิทาน
สอนใจนะคะว่าเอ่ออุบัติเหตุเกิดขึ้นได้
แต่อย่าทำอะไรที่มันพลาดเหมือนเดิมบ่อยๆ
หนังช้าๆทั้งสิ่งไม่ดีมันจะย้อนกลับมาที่
ตัวเราชายชายครับเทพ ka เวลาหมดจับเวลา
เวลาหมดเราจะต้องไปแล้วนะคะแล้วก็ไม่ใหญ่
แล้วครับเราก็ว่าถ้าเจอกันใหม่ครั้งหน้า
นะครับถ้าขอบคุณค่ะครูนี้สวัสดีครับครู
เอ๋หน้าเคยไปบ๊ายบายค่ะอ่ะ